hello everyone and welcome to the
continuation of some rapid fun we were
having yesterday you guys said you would
enjoy seeing more games so uh I will
play let's say one or two games uh
depending on you know how long it takes
if if it's um like if both of us uh
spend all over our time it's probably
going to make like a 20 minute video I'm
going to uh cap it at one but if the
games will go faster then I guess we
could play more in the previous one I've
actually played three we're playing
against nefer Pito um hxh who is also
streaming at the moment so that's pretty
cool uh so we are recording while he's
streaming it and we are going to go for
the Scandinavian defense uh very nice
all right so obviously he will play
great moves as he's also streaming to
his audience uh I have to be very
careful here uh and he goes for Knight
to C3 so we're going to play our
standard moves here you know just uh
Knight F6 A6 uh Knight okay A3 hm it's
kind kind of kind of a useful move I
just don't know if it's useful at the
moment but I don't really have a way of
exploiting this now so I'm just going to
continue developing uh but it is useful
as in some of the lines I do put my
Bishop on G4 okay so he immediately
stops that uh so probably we will put
our Bishop to D5 okay he goes for this
immediately what does he
want um H let's let's just develop first
I do want to play A6 but I usually play
A6 quickly uh so he he can't attack my
queen with Knight to B5 but here as his
Bishop is on B5 I don't have to rush it
so I just have to see if he will play it
with the D4 maybe
D3 and we'll uh take it from there all
right so he captures uh yeah he wants to
get rid of my light Square Bishop which
is perfectly fine but I don't know uh he
him having the white pieces I kind of
okay so he goes for this okay he doesn't
want to allow me to Advance my Pawn any
further might put the Knight here also
yeah that's
nice okay
so I guess we play E6 and
H yeah it's not a not a bad move order
not at
all
oh
okay there's I mean it's a bit slow it's
a bit slow but I can move the queen then
move the Knight and then play F6 and
kick away his Knight it's no big
deal yeah and now if D4 he he of course
wants to develop the bishop maybe to G5
um yeah let's play this right away now
Bishop G5 isn't very useful I'm just
going to kick it away with F6 so we'll
see how it
goes uh if he trades I will capture I
don't know yeah maybe trading wasn't uh
that bad of an option for him then uh
you know trade and push
C4
oh all right we're going to kick away
the Knight as that was our plan all
along now he frees up the B5 Square for
uh the
knight uh
okay this allows our Queen to get into
the game he's probably going to just
move it back to no he goes to D3
hm we could what could we
do so
really
H I'm going to play Queen to G6 I don't
think it's like a great move or anything
but it does put pressure on H3 and also
the Knight can't really move as it puts
pressure on see2 on the other hand uh I
don't know if my moves are all that
impressive so okay now
H hm
mhm yeah we should
definitely yeah we should definitely
capture this now capture
this I don't need to rush anything here
yeah everything is nicely defended let's
get our Bishop here he'll probably play
Bishop F4 which is very nice so if I
trade he can get the Knight to F4 with
tempo and then I don't have time to
capture the pawn here on the other hand
uh what if I just capture the Knight
that's the real question so the real
question is he will have some sort of
pressure against my king will I be able
to
survive yeah that is the real question
here he goes for that okay as we were
expecting
it yeah and we capture here he captures
there um so it's not I mean it's not
spectacular or
anything yeah now if he captures I might
even be able to capture this Pawn but I
can't yeah because if if I capture he's
just going to attack my queen and then
I'm going to lose the game terribly so
so I guess safest would be just uh play
this if he doubles up I should probably
just capture uh and then if he captures
capture the C3 Pawn could be a little
bit dangerous
but
yeah also I have to be a little bit
careful about checks he he does have a
check which can pick up my Pawn uh but
this also gives me a sort of a semi-open
g file to attack his king so I'm not
really that worried about losing that
pawn uh but yeah
H I like his position but I also like my
position so it's it's uh but I pretty
much uh it's like that in in all the
games okay some nasty pressure here H is
this anything I don't think it
is like he he shouldn't really allow me
to capture on C3
but
uh yeah he maybe even just Rook C1 does
look a bit passive
yes yeah but I do have weaknesses like
this is weak uh this can be weak uh this
Pawn is weak I I should play King to B8
at some point H just not sure if it's
useful anymore probably
is we'll all all depends on what he
plays
actually don't know who this
is nepo okay I'm going to check out okay
so he just goes for this so his idea is
that uh if I capture what's the idea
he's going to play Rook C1 that doesn't
really do anything I can just give a
check trade
everything and I'm going to be up a pawn
in a queen's end game
or am I missing something he might not
be interested in that at all but okay I
I definitely am intrigued am I
blundering a full Rook somewhere no
okay it's probably going to yeah he
doesn't have time H okay so I guess it's
a clean
Pawn hm
yeah I I think he maybe had uh some
better options
here maybe the the pawn push didn't
really achieve all that much yeah we're
going to
trade and go
into Queen and pawn end game being up a
pawn now I could do okay first we have
to prevent him from doing any checks and
picking up material that's kind of the
first thing to do or we could capture
this create a past Pawn
sort of allow him to maybe take one
Pawn Yeah but he can only take this one
he will not be able to check me here as
I will be controlling that so maybe
maybe it's a bit greedy but uh it could
also just be a good
move yeah I just
uh I don't want to blunder you know
really fine
game
uh
I could just play it uh with with queen
t7 and then offer try to offer a queen
trade which he will of course
avoid yeah if I can take and it's
winning then it's winning so so I'm
considering this and this and I have
time you know it's a rapid game so I
don't need to rush
anything ah so let's see if there's
maybe anything better hm
mhm let's see yeah this is very
nice yeah I I mean I know this is good I
just uh I it would be a shame not to be
greedy if it's okay to be greedy that's
uh that's all I'm going to
say
yeah I think we're going to be
greedy okay so Queen G4 pretty much only
move for him yeah he has to play that I
did consider F5 here just don't see the
upside of of that
move so this will give me some back rank
issues but nothing uh my opponent offers
a draw yeah we're still going to play a
little bit yeah I might lose it I'm not
saying I'm not uh capable of losing this
but
uh yeah I I would like to start pushing
right away but I can't he has
this yeah if I I block my queen if I
just play this
um yeah let's play a nice calm move
here he'll take another Pawn
and everything is fine yeah okay
perfectly
fine perfectly fine let's put the queen
here so we want our
King probably giving a few pawns to many
just to start uh pushing right
away but what are you going to do we're
going to centralize our Queen that's
that's worth the pawn
okay so he will do that and we start
what what I am in the square of the pawn
that's for
sure like that can't be good for
him okay uh we're
faster yeah we're in the Square of the
pawn so for those of you who don't know
this is the square of the pawn as long
as my king is here I can stop the pawns
not really a
problem uh he's definitely going to have
to include his
King yeah now he just can't stop my Pawn
maybe okay maybe I didn't calculate it
perfectly but
um yeah definitely the king is the one
that was supposed to enter the
game
okay so his King is now coming but it is
far too late
yeah far too late for that all right so
he will give one check but it doesn't
really
matter yeah
okay and that's all there is um yeah
let's give this
check then this check then this check
okay so he resigns of course uh but we
will check let me just check here okay
we got some 85 points of rating that's
very
nice uh let me just check
here
uh oh we got uh we got some audience
here as the gentleman was streaming so
let's just
uh ah so okay so everything was okay
this is a standard white advantage of
0.3 nothing spectacular here this was
fine fine fine fine fine
uh yeah A4 not the best here so Knight
B4 obviously I can take advantage of the
weird positioning here but I thought
yeah okay he just defends it with the
rook and
uh but yeah obviously night B before was
best F6 not
terrible uh Queen here okay Knight Queen
of3 I capture captures okay pretty much
a draw here I play Bishop captur that's
perfectly fine fine fine fine fine fine
yeah 00 0 yeah here it's um yeah yeah
that's the move I didn't like and the
engine doesn't like it either I took on
C3 that's great Queen yeah Queen F5
obviously better yeah now here he just
allows me to okay so what could have
been done better let me just check uh
yeah okay Queen E6 is the move yeah that
um I should have played it's the one
that I was uh considering but I went for
the greedy option both of them are
better for black uh it's it's just that
Queen to A6 is um not as greedy so I
should have played that yeah okay check
okay captures uh H6 yeah okay captures
so this should be a draw now uh but I
was able to somehow win yeah he he
should just capture on H7 and then fight
with the Queen Once he gives the queen
trade uh you can see the the double
question mark it was a blunder so yeah
here uh it's actually a draw after this
move captures captures yeah King B6 just
uh wins the game uh but yeah of course
it was important to get in in the square
of the pawn uh of course if you know
that then it's easy to find the move
yeah but now of course the pawn is
Unstoppable uh so yeah not uh not okay
if I if I mess this up then I should not
be recording chess games uh but yeah uh
okay so this was a nice one oh yeah okay
15 minutes for one game as we are now
climbing up the rating a little bit the
games will get longer so maybe I'm going
to uh stick with one uh one game per
video well we'll see how it goes for
tomorrow if it's going to be a short one
then I'm going to make like two of them
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it um as usual you can
check through my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and everything
else that's happening in the Chess World
uh the next video comes from the girls
um uh World Championship uh so stay
tuned for that it's really an awesome
one uh see you soon